so the new trailer for The Super Mario
Brothers movie is now out in this video
we're going to be breaking down all the
Easter eggs hidden details and things he
missed in it this is packed with
references from beginning to end and is
it just me does Mario sound exactly like
Chris Pratt can't exactly put my finger
on why but that's your first Easter egg
and the teaser begins much like how
Mario began all the way back in his
first game appearance released in 1981
the game Donkey Kong saw Jumpman being
introduced to the world the basic
structure was that you played Jumpman
and had to rescue the princess from the
clutches of the evil Donkey Kong the
structure at each level was litted with
red metal girders that you had to run
and jump along in order to get to the
top we actually see these girders early
on in the teaser and it's the platform
that Mario and Donkey Kong end up
fighting a pawn let's say fighting it's
pretty one-sided that's what you get
a Donkey Kong will be voiced by Seth
Rogen and he's gonna be a big character
in the movie
now in one of the best references I've
ever seen pay close attention to that
crowd noise
this is actually pulled from the
original Mario 3 commercial
huge alerts to Tanuki Joe on Twitter for
that one and it shows how much attention
did he tell their pain early on we see
Mario walking out and to the left and
right of him you can catch some weights
there's also a sword standing up in the
back and some wool carvings that look
like a giant ape there's then a barrel
and Donkey Kong used to throw these at
Jumpman and also jump in them too in his
solo games before he was shot across the
sky now as he enters the arena we then
get some classic iconography from the
pairs games firstly there are floating
brick structures with a golden one in
the middle it looks like the ones you
encana in pretty much every single Mario
game is then the golden question mark
blocks on their own and also some tires
when we pull out to see the gator and
fall we can also spot some more barrels
and platforms as well as a blue ladder
which is what Jumpman used to climb up
the arena itself is a giant statue of
Kong ride at the back and in a nice bit
of attention to detail this actually
looks like like it's 8-bit just below
that is a more modernized Donkey Kong
face and on the throne sets my man
Cranky Kong in the game law this was the
first Donkey Kong that Mario faced off
against all the way back in the 1981
game he sort of appeared in the other
games as a cranky old character that
tells Donkey Kong off because kids today
ain't got no respect you hear that kids
that ain't got no respect
all right that's the car now Mario says
let's go but great impression before he
jumps in head first and this is a
catchphrase that the character often
drops in the games Donkey Kong has his
famous red tie on and you might notice
that that has the letters DK on it up in
the observation box we can also see toad
along with Princess Peach there's also
some bananas there as well and these are
what Donkey Kong used to collect in his
solo games cranky eats one later and
he's pretty much the donkey King Kong of
this entire land when we see the map
later on we can actually see their line
at the top next to the volcano one to
the left of it is a desert pyramid
similar to the one in Mario 64. as the
Mushroom Kingdom just below it and this
will be the first place that Mario's
stopping off at deserts have of course
popped up in lots of Mario games
um most notably Mario 3 and you know you
you always get the sand pits and and
that sort of thing going on with them
now to the right of that is Yoshi's
Island and we know we'll be visiting
here do you do a quick shot on the
teaser that pops up later on there's
also Bowser's land which if you look
closely has some ice and we know from
the first trail that Bowser does invade
the penguin land which I actually think
this is so a little Theory time
see everyone's saying this is bowserland
including me just 20 seconds ago but
again I think it's probably the penguin
land and that Bowser arrived there on
his ship and then took it over this was
of course shown in the first trailer and
then it probably turned into the lava
land we see and then he's flying out
from there in order to take over the
rest the land at the top is probably
where he came from and then he moved
down from there in order to take over
everything else anyway that's in it dude
who's a pretty short pretty bit of a
waste of time time moving on also nice
bit of attention to detail is that
there's a golden star above the ship as
he flies over the land anyway the
audience itself is also made up of apes
and you can see they've got different
clothes and costumes on huge hit us
Nintendo Land for pawning out that when
Mario first exits the tunnel they can
see characters that might be from the
Donkey Kong games searches rankly Kong
the left of the tunnel there's two
characters with bonnets on and these
look exactly like the same one that she
wears in the games when we pull out to a
lighter shot we can also see two
characters holding big letters that say
DK and also smaller chimps that resemble
Diddy Kong you know these are obviously
just kids rather than being him but a
nice bit of attention to detail to have
the kids looking like this and Mario
gets smashed like it's a like button and
also make sure you subscribe because
we've got videos like this that point
out everything Yoshi and everything yo
don't Chief fake anyway could to
Bowser's Castle not sure if you know who
I am
but I'm about to rule the world wow
yay so Bowser's got Luigi at this point
and I'm guessing that it'll happen for
most of the movie this seems like it's
early on and the pair probably gets
separated upon being sucked into the
Mushroom Kingdom we have a bit where
they are clearly in the normal World
which we know from the post is is in
fact Brooklyn Luigi has his toolbox and
later on when we see him getting sucked
into the world he can also see has it
there we know from the first trailer
that when Mario lands that he's by
himself so I'm guessing they get
separated during this and Luigi then
crashes somewhere which is where he's
captured by Bowser the movie is probably
gonna be about Mario rescuing his
brother because we know from later shots
that Pete is working alongside him
typically she's been someone that needs
to be saved but here it's the women
helping to save the man so take that
patriarchy I'm sick of sexism and gaming
and we do get a shot where Mario seems
to be working on his day-to-day job
fixing a sink and this could be the
opening of the film that has them
getting pulled across during their
conversation we actually see his army
which is made up of pretty much every
Trooper he has it's gonna be exhausting
going through this but let's do it now
the first ones we see fly away from the
camera and no we only get a split second
shot of these I think these might be
swoopers which are now just called
swoops most of the forces here are
Koopas and we can see all the different
color shells that they typically have
and the ones we can see with the helmets
on are the Hammer Bros and there's quite
a lot of them too there's a big one that
has a couple huddled around them and a
piranha plant swoops in and steals some
food piranha plants are there quite a
lot too and you'll be able to recognize
them from their red coloring and the
white spots they have shy guys appear
there as well and they're sort of your
Niche villain after being first
introduced in Super Mario Brothers 2.
one of them appears to have a black mask
on rather than a white one and again
shout out to Nintendo Land for pointing
out that this is actually a snippet
great Channel over there that they have
going to loads of Nintendo stuff and
definitely go check them out if you want
some amazing Nintendo trivia now there's
also some Goombas as well and as we zoom
in we can see a stack of them standing
on top of each other they're all doing
some pretty funny stuff here with a
hammer bro tucking his shell in as a
piranha plank goes to bite him there's a
couple of Koopas doing a limbo stick too
and the trailer is absolutely packed
there's a bomb on that explodes as we
get closer and this takes us into a
transition of the next shot however if
you pull back you'll also notice a
spiked Red Shell crawling across the
floor and this belongs to a spiny I also
love how the area is full of Bowser
statues and there's one there as well
when Luigi is first brought in showing
how bad his ego is he's gonna be voiced
by Jack Black and I really can't wait to
see what he brings to the movie there's
a really cool show away pulls a hair out
of Luigi's mustache and starts to
interrogate him about his brother whilst
he does the usual villain monologue
could it the Mushroom Kingdom and we see
Princess Peach in her classic pink dress
up the stairs and behind her we can also
see the stained glass window which first
debuted back in Mario 64. this was
released as its own poster just before
the trailer dropped there are a couple
of significant details in it at the top
is a star and I'm guessing that this is
where they're kept at about a minute 34
on the teaser we get a split second shot
where Bowser Burns a nice doorway and at
the top we can also see a star there too
this probably belonged to the Penguin
and taking it from there might explain
how he has one the poster also has a
painting to the left hand side it looks
like it's from Total Mountain paintings
are of course important in the Mushroom
Kingdom as 64 showed us that we could
jump into them and be transported after
other worlds Lassie the windows in the
castle have clouds painted onto them
which looked like they're ripped right
out of the games now we get a shot from
behind Peach's head and can see lots of
toadstools there on the ground is an
interesting detail though as we can see
a star emblem Cassie mine back to Mario
64 and something similar was on the
ground in that too when you first
entered the castle now that back of this
room we can see two turd guards that
have helmets and axes guessing these are
either taken out or they run away which
is why they're on the floor in the next
shot tend to lean more towards them
running away which is why there's just
one toad with her instead of the big
group we see in the earlier scene
peaches change throughout the two and
now she's wearing her motorcycle outfit
from the later Mario Kart games
originally she just wore the dress but
this changed over time she rides a
motorbike later on but we'll talk about
this more when we get to that section
Peach will be raised by anyatella joy
and he's gonna be taking the fight to
Bowser which we get in the next scene
shout outs to my man bamalam for
pointing out that the trees to the left
of this shot have stripes on them and
they look similar to the one from Super
Bell Hill we then see Mario running
through training and this quote-unquote
level is packed with a lot of Easter
eggs exhausting again but let's break it
down so in the middle a flag Rises up
similar to the ones that you'd see at
the end of levels there's also several
green pipes looking like the classic
ones from the game as well as some
cannons these would fire out Bullet Bill
who we later see popping up in the scene
this charges Mario and in the next shot
we can see that he gets hit by a Banzai
Bell if you look closely you'll see that
it's made out of fabric rather than
being an actual bullet it's not real and
this is mirrored in the pipes that have
piranha plants popping out of them if
you look closely you'll see that they
have joints in them and because of this
I'm guessing they're fake this is
reflected in the Fireballs 2 which Mario
gets really close to however if you look
closely at them you'll see they're
actually fake again cementing this idea
that it's not really dangerous this all
just seems like it's part of the
obstacle course that's basically set up
to put Mario to his Paces you also have
golden blocks as well as breaks being
used for Ledges to the right we can see
slightly different platforms and in the
games these would drop away when you
stood on them this happens to Mario
later on when he jumps off a switching
platform on top of this we also have eye
blocks from Super Mario World and some
blocks that have spikes on them from
here we cut the Mario Toad and Peach
walking along a giant bridge at this
point Mario is hit by a cheap cheap
which is sort of a flying fish that used
to jump up in the game hated avoiding
those hooks they do me [ __ ] heading
now nice little detail is that peach
pulls the cheap cheap off Mario's face
and then it hits Toad and starts sucking
on him at this point we get what for me
is this trailer's money shot we see
Mario in the Tanuki suit swooping down
and it's probably my favorite moment in
the teaser might be tied with a Mario
Kart one later on but still great thing
to have in the trailer now he Glides
down from the sky and we can see
Bowser's airship closing in on the
castle which we get a bird's eye view of
there's six stars and a path surrounding
the castle and this reminded me a lot of
the Star Road from Super Mario World
Mario swoops down and in a blink and
you'll miss a moment you might spot
there's a bullet bull chasing him from
the water this might be a Bullet Bill
might be a Bandai one but it happened so
fast that it's difficult to fully make
out the size proportions see guys eyes
Size Matters and that's why we're
actually selling a seism at his T-shirt
over at our midshop Zero edition telling
you head over there right now now Mario
isn't the only one who'll be getting a
power up and Peach will be embracing
some flower power to take on Bowser in
the next shot we see her in a field of
fire flowers and Peach ends up touching
one she holds it in her hand and at this
point you might notice that her outfit
is white and red this is actually her
fire Peach costume which changes the
color of her dress to give her a fire
one not saying the costume is fire well
I am but you know what I mean now we
then get a sunset shot and this is
followed by Yoshi's Island you see loads
of the little guys running along past
the stream but no green one so the
trailer is 0 out of 10 would not
recommend to a friend I don't want to
drop a theory time again but I do think
we will see a green one at some point
and the reason they're holding it back
here is to probably give one to Mario
later on we then get the penguin Kingdom
which I'm guessing is how the movie
starts before we go to Brooklyn to meet
Mario and Luigi G this leads perfectly
into the pipe sucking scene and that
then follows it over the top of this
Peach talks about there being lots of
galaxies out there and for a sequel we
might do a Mario galaxy type movie where
he travels to different planets lastly
is another money shot it's the bloody
Mario Kart scene now here we see Peach
on her motorbike and also Donkey Kong
it's basically like a Mad Max shot here
with Mario getting his classic red card
this takes place on Rainbow Road and
it's a location that's ripped right out
of the games there's lots of characters
here and behind Donkey Kong we can see
what looks to be Funky Kong he's a very
obscure character but I love him and
looking at the shades and bandana it
does seem like it's him most of the
characters here are in fact Apes so I'm
guessing they've just come off the back
of the Donkey Kong fight and are heading
out to take on Bowser to the left
there's also what appears to be Kitty
Kong but no Diddy like a two pack album
which is outrageous either way there's
lots of cards here including toad who
gets a monster truck one and Mario drops
there
I mean uh
I guess
it's like it doesn't really fit in with
the rest of the performance he's giving
you know what it reminds me of yet when
cyborg said booyah in Justice League and
they've just kind of dropped a
catchphrase for the sake of dropping a
catchphrase the guy's getting enough
online though for the voice and I don't
want to add to it so instead I will say
that I think the film looks awesome and
it'll know that'll be the best Mario
movie we've ever had sure it won't be
difficult to top the last one but
they've completely nailed the aesthetic
air and absolutely everything looks like
it's ripped right out of the games hope
this breakdown is surely how much
they've put into it and even the final
shot has him drifting which is directly
from Mario Kart they have completely
packed every shot with something that
links into the franchise and it makes me
think that they're really putting in the
effort here to make sure it's going to
be as close to the games as we can get
and that I appreciate I think putting
Mario into an animated movie like this
is the best way to go about it and it
looks like it's gonna be one of the best
video game movies of all time this was a
big Main trailer to launch the movie and
I'm really hyped to see what comes out
of it obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts as well so make sure you
comment below and let me know if there's
anything I missed the trailer is
completely stacked so I'm sure there's
some stuff there like from from a Mario
game that was only released in Japan or
something but this was basically me
going through it frame by frame to see
what references I could find now as a
thank you for dropping a comment you'll
be entered into a competition where
we're giving away three copies of House
of the dragon on the 15th of December
all you have to do to be with a chance
of winning is to like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the trailer you pick the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on the screen right now so that's
you then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers if you want something else to
watch them make sure you check out our
breakdown of the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special which will be linked on
screen right now lots of things in that
to talk about so definitely head over
there right after this by the way thanks
for singing through the video make sure
you stay locked because we've got lots
of trailer breakdown is coming up I hope
to see on the next one take care peace